-Good evening. Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
President Biden signed
an executive order yesterday
limiting
the government's ability
to use commercial spyware
that could be used
to hack citizens' phones
or, as he put it,
"We're going back to landlines."
[ Laughter ]
The Manhattan grand jury
investigating allegations
that former President Trump
made illegal hush money payments
met yesterday
without voting
on a criminal indictment.
Okay. In the words
of Stormy Daniels,
what is taking so long?
[ Laughter ]
Look, until we see
that perp walk,
I'm just going to have
to keep showing this one.
♪♪
I do hope...
When he does have his perp walk,
I do hope they play
that brass band.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump
was interviewed last night
by Fox News host Sean Hannity.
"Thanks for having me back,"
said Hannity and Trump
at the same time.
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview with
Fox News host Sean Hannity,
former President Trump denied
having an affair with
adult film star Stormy Daniels,
which would actually be
a better explanation
for the hush money.
"Don't tell anybody.
We didn't do it."
[ Laughter ]
In the same interview,
former President Trump claimed
that if
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
did not win the Republican
gubernatorial primary in 2018,
he would be working
in a pizza parlor.
Why do I feel like the only jobs
Trump knows are ones from porn?
[ Laughter ]
"If I didn't endorse
Ron right now,
he would be working as either
a plumber or a stepson."
[ Laughter ]
Trump also said last night
that he has tapes
of the FBI raid on his
Mar-A-Lago residence,
but he did have to record
over some stuff.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, some...
[ Laughs ]
Some sympathy for Eric tonight.
Noted. Noted.
President Biden called
on Congress yesterday
to pass an assault weapons ban,
which is sort of like
calling on McDonald's
to make you a Whopper.
They could do it.
They just won't.
[ Laughter ]
Former Vice President Mike Pence
is set tomorrow
to travel to Iowa,
which I think is actually
the name of a color
at Sherwin-Williams.
[ Laughter ]
North Dakota Governor --
[ Applause ]
North Dakota...
[ Laughter ]
North Dakota Governor
Doug Burgum
is reportedly considering
running for president.
And if you're wondering
what his chances are,
that ain't him
and nobody noticed.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
I'd vote for that guy though.
That guys does not like --
seem like he likes the path
this country is on.
[ Laughter ]
Authorities in California
recently arrested a man
who allegedly burglarized
several optometry offices.
Witnesses described the subject
as a person between
four and eight feet tall
and very blurry.
[ Laughter ]
They also -- They also thought
that last guy with Doug Burgum.
[ Laughter ]
And finally today
was National Hot Tub Day,
except in New York,
where the "jets" don't work.
And that, you guys...
[ Audience shouting ]
Oh, come on.
Come on.
[ Laughs ]